Let's see the solution to
our write-update versus
write-invalidate quiz.
We have two cores that run our program,
where basically, core 0 writes, and
then core 1 reads, and
that happens 1,000 times.
How many bus uses do we get with
the write-update protocol, and
then with the write-invalidate protocol?
We have already seen a similar
example for write-update.
What's going to happen is, with the
shared and dirty bits we do not really
save much because there is
actual sharing going on here, so
we are going to have a broadcast on
the bus for each of these writes, so
we get 1,000 bus accesses
from these writes,
and the very first read is going to be
a miss, so we get the bus access there.
So overall we get 1,001 bus uses.
In a write-invalidate protocol,
let's see what happens.
Core 0 writes, this is a miss.
We send something to the bus, and
now we get the only copy of this data.
Core 1 reads, has a miss,
core 0 has to supply the data.
So, so far we had 1 and 1, and
then what happens is ore 0 writes.
We know that there is a sharer now
because this core has a block, so
we need to send out an invalidation.
That means that when core 1 reads next,
it's going to have a miss and
use the bus.
So this will repeat 1000 times, and
we get a total of 2000 bus uses,
so as you can see write-update Is a lot
more efficient than write-validate,
if we actually have a pattern where one
core produces the data continuously and
the other one keeps reading the data.
If we have a pattern in which one core
is the producer of all the data, and
the other core is the consumer
because the data flow
from the producer to the consumer
through the same memory location.
In the write update protocol involves
just the update by the write,
but the read can then find
the data in the cache,
whereas in the invalidation protocol the
write just sends out an invalidation,
and then the reader has to still
suffer a miss to obtain the data.